we were here to try food that we hated
his kids um I wouldn't say I'm
necessarily looking forward to it but I
am open to expanding my palate Oh see
that positive attitude so yes I'm
terrified honestly when I was growing up
I had a problem with old tomatoes that's
just that explosion of goo that makes me
want to throw up so oh my god this is
what I'm talking about
mmm when I was like four or five but I
don't like all of their gross I'm
actually not that excited it's our heart
man how do people eat these at parties
so much yes goodbye
I'm curious what would you you don't
want to go down I brush my teeth I don't
want to ruin it with one of these I
refuse to eat in my whole life all pie
it's mushy like a peach I don't like raw
off the tree or in a pie because it's
mushy all the time
it's just heating it up making it more
mushy look at that just crust and love
it yes this makes me happy okay
[Music]
no one else use this - that bag either
way I'd be even better than this I grew
up in Maryland
my friends eat a lot of seafood but like
I don't even eat sushi I think the smell
is pretty bad I'm just color yeah and
it's on top of vegetables makes it even
worse
Cheers Wow
I thought I could stop that bad I
thought it was gonna be so much like
scaley er Oh she'll hate it that's worth
the shot ten years ago my dad was eating
it and I was like I'll try a bite and I
tried it and I was like yep still hate
it and I might have had this in Mexico
like ten years ago
I don't remember why are there carrots I
think these are the sliced version of
what was inside of there that makes more
sense
yeah but they they do look like you want
to feed each other is that yeah this is
weird
we just know a little bit oh yeah yep
yeah it's not even sweetie
exactly there's so many better fruits
out there I could go down the list
[Music]
pineapple strawberry please can't go
banana kiwi cute